nous ne pourrions jamais mesurer le racisme.
« Nous mesurons l'estime de soi », ai-je dit.
« Pourquoi ne pourrions-nous pas
mesurer le racisme si nous en faisons l'effort ? »
Alors j'ai fait l'effort
et j'ai développé trois barèmes.
Le premier reflète les expériences de discrimination majeures,
comme être licencié ou arrêté par la police injustement.
Mais la discrimination apparaît aussi dans des situations moins sérieuses,
donc mon deuxième barème,
ou « le barème de discrimination quotidienne »,
reflète neuf éléments
qui regroupent les expériences
où vous êtes traité avec moins de politesse que les autres,
vous recevez un service de moindre qualité que les autres au restaurant ou au magasin
ou les gens manifestent de la peur envers vous.
Ce barème reflète
comment la dignité et le respect
des gens que la société n'estime pas
sont piétinés quotidiennement.
Les enquêtes ont montré
que les niveaux élévés de discrimination
amènent un risque élevé pour un grand nombre de maladies,
de la tension artérielle à l’obésité abdominale
en passant par le cancer du sein, les maladies cardiaques
et même une mort prématurée.
Ce qui est frappant, certaines conséquences sont observées très jeune.
Par exemple, une étude sur des adolescents noirs
a montré que les adolescents qui ont subi des niveaux plus élevés de discrimination
avaient plus d'hormones du stress,
de tension artérielle
et plus de poids à l'âge de 20 ans.
Cependant,
le stress venant de la discrimination
n'est seulement qu'un aspect.
La discrimination et le racisme
ont aussi une importance dans d'autres aspects primordiaux pour la santé.
Par exemple, il y a de la discrimination dans les soins médicaux.
En 1999, l'académie nationale de médecine
m'a demandé de faire partie du comité
qui démontra, sur la base de preuves scientifiques,
que les Noirs et les autres minorités
reçoivent des soins de moins bonne qualité que les Blancs.
C'était vrai pour tout type de soins médicaux,
du plus simple
au plus sophistiqué technologiquement.
Une explication à cette tendance
était un phénomène qu'on appelle « préjugé implicite »
ou « discrimination inconsciente ».
Des recherches menées pendant des décennies par des psychologues
indiquent que si nous avons des stéréotypes négatifs
sur un groupe dans notre subconscient
et que nous rencontrons quelqu'un de ce groupe,
nous discriminerons cette personne.
Nous la traiterons différemment.
C'est un processus inconscient. C'est un processus automatique.
C'est un processus subtil, mais c'est normal
et ça arrive même chez ceux qui ont les meilleures intentions.
Mais plus je recherchais
l'impact du racisme sur la santé,
moins l'impact était visible.
Il y a la discrimination institutionnelle,
qui réfère à la discrimination
qui existe dans les processus des institutions sociales.
La ségrégation résidentielle par race,
qui a amené les Noirs et les Blancs à vivre dans des quartiers très différents,
c'est un exemple classique de racisme institutionnel.
Un des secrets les mieux gardés d'Amérique
est que la ségrégation résidentielle
est la cause secrète
des inégalités raciales aux États-Unis.
En Amérique, le lieu où vous vivez
détermine votre accès aux opportunités
en termes d'éducation, d'emploi,
de logement et même d'accès aux soins médicaux.
Une étude des 171 plus grandes villes aux États-Unis
a conclu qu'il n'y a pas une ville
où les Blancs vivent dans les mêmes conditions que les Noirs
et que les pires quartiers blancs
sont considérablement meilleurs que les quartiers noirs moyens.
Une autre étude a montré
que si on pouvait éliminer statistiquement
la ségrégation résidentielle,
on effacerait complètement la différence de revenus, d'éducation et d'emploi
entre les Blancs et les Noirs
et réduirait les différences raciales des mères célibataires
de deux tiers.
Tous ces aspects sont dus à la ségrégation.
J'ai aussi appris
comment les stéréotypes négatifs
et l'image des Noirs dans notre culture
créent et entretiennent
la discrimination institutionnelle et la discrimination individuelle.
Un groupe de chercheurs a développé une base de données
qui contient les livres,
magazines et articles
qu'un Américain moyen éduqué lit durant sa vie.
Cela nous permet de regarder dans cette base de données
et de voir comment les Américains ont vu les mots associés entre eux
en grandissant.
Quand on voit le mot « Noir » apparaître dans la culture américaine,
qu'est-ce qui lui est associé ?
« Pauvre »,
« violent »,
« religieux »,
« paresseux »,
« joyeux »,
« dangereux ».
Quand le mot « Blanc » apparaît,
les mots souvent associés
sont « riche »,
« progressiste »,
« conventionnel »,
« entêté »,
« prospère »,
« éduqué ».
Quand un officier de police
agit de manière excessive quand il voit un homme noir non armé
et le perçoit comme étant violent et dangereux,
on n'a pas forcément à faire à un mauvais flic par nature.
On a peut-être seulement à faire
à un Américain normal
qui reflète ce à quoi il a été exposé
en étant élevé
dans cette société.
De ma propre expérience,
je pense que l'ethnie
n'a pas à être un facteur déterminant notre destin.
J'ai émigré aux États-Unis
depuis l'île de Sainte-Lucie des Caraïbes
vers la fin des années 70
dans le but d'accéder à une meilleure éducation.
Et durant ces 40 dernières années,
je m'en suis bien sorti.
Ma famille m'a soutenu,
j'ai travaillé dur,
je m'en suis bien sorti.
Mais il m'a fallu plus d'efforts pour réussir.
J'ai reçu une bourse pour les minorités de l'Université du Michigan.
Oui, je suis un enfant de la discrimination positive.
Sans discrimination positive,
je ne serais pas arrivé ici.
Mais durant les 40 dernières années,
l'Amérique noire a connu moins de succès que j'en ai connu.
En 1978, les foyers afro-américains
gagnaient 59 cents pour chaque dollar perçu par un blanc.
En 2015,
les foyers afro-américains gagnent toujours 59 cents
pour chaque dollar perçu par un foyer blanc
et le fossé racial de la richesse est encore plus stupéfiant.
Pour chaque dollar de richesse qu'un blanc possède,
les foyers noirs possèdent six centimes et les Hispaniques en possèdent sept.
Le fait est
que le racisme
crée un système truqué
qui désavantage systématiquement certains groupes ethniques aux États-Unis.
Pour paraphraser Platon,
il n'y a rien de plus injuste
que le traitement égal de personnes qui ne sont pas égales.
Et c'est pourquoi je suis engagé
à travailler pour éradiquer le racisme.
J’apprécie particulièrement le fait
que je me tiens sur les épaules
de ceux qui ont sacrifié jusqu'à leur vie pour ouvrir les portes
que j'ai franchies.
Je veux m'assurer que ces portes restent ouvertes
et que tout le monde puisse les franchir.
Robert Kennedy a dit :
« Chaque fois qu'un homme » - ou une femme, j'ajouterais -
« se bat pour une idée,
agit pour améliorer le sort des autres
ou se bat contre l'injustice,
il renvoie une petite vague d'espoir,
et ces vagues peuvent créer un courant
qui peut faire tomber les plus grands murs d'oppression et de résistance. »
Je suis optimiste aujourd'hui
parce que dans toute l'Amérique,
j'ai vu des vagues d'espoir.
Le centre médical de Boston
a ajouté des avocats à l'équipe médicale
pour que les médecins puissent améliorer la santé de leurs patients
car les avocats s'occupent des besoins non médicaux des patients.
L'Université de Loma Linda a construit une école
à proximité, à San Bernardino,
pour qu'en plus de fournir des soins médicaux,
ils puissent offrir des compétences professionnelles
et des formations professionnelles
aux membres d'une communauté minoritaire et à faibles revenus
pour qu'ils acquièrent les compétences nécessaires pour avoir un emploi correct.
À Chapel Hill, en Caroline du Nord,
le projet Abécédaire a compris
comment assurer la réduction des risques de maladies cardiaques
pour les Noirs ayant environ 35 ans
en offrant des services de crèche de qualité
de la naissance à l'âge de cinq ans.
Dans des centres d'activités scolaires dans tous les États-Unis,
Wintley Phipps et la US Dream Academy
brisent le cycle d’incarcération
en offrant des mentorats et enrichissements de qualité
aux enfants de détenus
et les enfants qui ont accumulé du retard à l'école.
À Huntsville, en Alabama,
l'Université d'Oakwood,
une institution historiquement noire,
montre comment on peut améliorer la santé des adultes noirs
en incluant une évaluation de santé
dans l'orientation des troisièmes années
et en donnant à ces étudiants les outils dont ils ont besoin
pour faire des choix sains
et leur fournir un relevé de santé annuel
pour qu'ils puissent suivre leurs progrès.
Et à Atlanta, en Géorgie,
Purpose Built Communities a éradiqué les effets négatifs de la ségrégation
en transformant une cité
infestée par la drogue et la criminalité
en un oasis de logements aux revenus hétérogènes,
de réussites académiques,
de bien-être communautaire
et de plein emploi.
Et enfin,
il y a la solution de Devine.
Professeur Patricia Devine
de l'Université du Wisconsin
nous a montré comment nous pouvons nous battre
contre nos préjugé cachés
et les réduire de manière efficace.
Chacun d'entre nous
peut être une vague d'espoir.
Cette tâche ne sera pas toujours facile,
mais l'ancien Juge de la Cour Suprême, Thurgood Marshall,
nous a dit : « Nous devons nous battre.
Nous devons nous battre contre l'indifférence.
Nous devons nous battre contre l'apathie.
Nous devons nous battre contre la haine et la méfiance.
Nous devons nous battre
car l'Amérique peut mieux faire,
parce que l'Amérique n'a d'autre choix que de mieux faire. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)